hey everyone so over the past couple of
weeks i've been intending to make more
sort of youtube specific content
and i have a lot of ideas for
instructive material and um i've sort of
procrastinated but this is going to be
the first video where i sort of start
consistently making
more content specifically for youtube
and
um the first thing i wanted to do is
make more videos on topics that kind of
got a lot of positive feedback one of
them
was a series of requests that i would
get on my stream
to do more videos where i basically go
through problems puzzles
of different levels and explain my
thought process in a lot of depth and
sort of give
specific pointers on how to solve
exercises and how to use them properly
for tactical improvement
and that is what we're going to be doing
in this video so
we are going to be solving a
exercise is probably about 10 exercises
in the approximate intermediate range
and using chest.com's puzzle tool i'm
going to set the rating range of the
problems to be from 1500 to 2200 so it's
going to be a pretty broad range i did a
previous series where i did puzzle rush
survival this is going to be a little
bit different so we're going to get
exercises of various difficulties
and i'm going to try to explain in as
much depth
and breadth as possible the exact uh
process that i use to solve these
exercises and hopefully you'll find it
helpful let's jump in
okay
so first problem
is a really easy one
now the very first thing i see is that
black's got a weak back rank what i mean
by that is that the king has no
escape on the seventh rank
by the way compared to white's uh back
rank white has a square on h2 so there's
no back rank problems
and
black has no pieces on that back rank so
i'm immediately looking for various
checks that i can deliver on that
background now queen c8 check would be
great except there's a bishop there
controlling c8
queen d8 check also seems impossible but
i also noticed that there's a rook on d1
so this is a classic example of an x-ray
where
even though there is an opposing piece
between two of your pieces if it's a
long-range piece such as a rook it's
going to be kind of ghost controlling
the other piece so when we play queen d8
the the black rook has to take the queen
and the white rook is going to swoop in
and capture d8 with checkmate so queen
d8 and now rook takes d8 is made okay
that was a pretty simple exercise let's
move on
all right so black has just played e5
it seems to be a complicated opening
position
now i noticed a couple of things
material seems to be equal
i noticed that we are in a pin so
it's probably not going to be knight
take c5 but
i do notice something interesting about
the placement of black's queen which is
that if this knight ever does land on e5
it's going to be counter-attacking
black's queen so it might not be such a
big problem that we're pinned
now the immediate knight takes e5 is bad
but not because black takes the queen if
black takes the queen then we take
black's queen
and then if black takes on d7 then we
can recapture that bishop and we're up a
pawn
the issue though with taking on e5 is
that black can simply recapture that
knight
and our queen is going to be under
attack so we're going to end up a piece
down but what if we take on e5 with the
pawn let's try to flesh that out
okay so
probably black is going to recapture
with let's say the knight okay
again if we take that knight with our
knight then black takes it with his
bishop and again our queen is hanging
that's not a problem but
so we take with a pawn
black takes with a knight what if we
take that knight with our bishop
then after black takes that bishop with
his bishop black is no longer any pieces
controlling e5
we can take that
with our knight and then we have that
situation i mentioned originally where
both queens are hanging except we've
already won a piece
and we seem to preserve that extra piece
after bishop takes d1 knight takes d7 so
i think it's just d takes c5
and now very important we don't take
with the knight because then knight
takes c5 and black is fine we take with
the bishop
okay so they take on f3 but i think the
critical line would have been knight
takes c5
and then knight takes e5 bishop takes f3
now we take with the knight and we
preserve our defense of the bishop we're
up a piece
so i would say the important thing in
this exercise is to realize that unless
your king is pinned in which case it is
literally illegal to move the pin piece
a lot of people seem to think of it the
same way when their queen has been but
you're you can move a piece that's
pinned to the queen
and often you can move it if you're
attacking the opposing queen so if your
knight is the one that's pinned you
always want to identify situations where
your opponent's queen is attackable by
that knight because that could be a way
to escape the pen in this case knight
takes c5 at the right moment was exactly
a way to do that so that placement of
black screen is super pivotal here
okay we've got a pretty messy position
here
okay white's going this way
so the first thing i just to get my
bearings here let's figure out what
happens if white makes a queen
well if white makes a queen that there
is going to be an unfortunate alignment
of king and queen black has bishop e6
check
and black wins the queen back that
doesn't seem to be correct
so what i'm immediately thinking about
is a way of trying to get black's king
onto a square
such that we could promote with check
okay so in order for that to happen we
need to start looking at checks
the only check that i see right knight
f5 is ridiculous because bishop can just
take
is is knight g8 check
okay so what happens after knight ga
check if the king drops back to h7 then
we have checkmate on g5 that's also a
fork
unfortunately i think the king walks up
to h5
and if that knight goes to f6 then the
king hides on h4
and neither of the two knights has any
way of checking the king and again if we
promote in that position then black
still has bishop e6 because we haven't
dislodged black's queen now are there
any other checks in this position well
there is one other check
and that is to under promote to a knight
and make a third knight g8 equals night
so let's calculate that and notice how
i'm not really trying i'm not ruling
that option out because it looks absurd
i know that three knights can
collaborate to give checkmate and you
should understand that too because
black's king is so close to the side of
the board so g8 equals knight the king
has two escape squares if the king moves
back to h7 i think it's the mate is
pretty easy we move this knight into f6
and then after the king comes into the
corner the other knight swings around to
g6 and that's made
so after g at night the king has to go
up to h5
but then just using process of
elimination that newly promoted knight
can go back to f6 with a check and if
the king moves up to h4 the knight g6 is
made notice how this knight guards g3
and if the king moves back down to h6
then this knight goes to g8 with mate
now i know that's
you know that's a little bit confusing
but
what i would do is pause the video and
try to make sure that you can understand
in your head
all of the mating lines after g8 equals
knight
okay so they move up to h5
by the way the reason we don't don't go
with this knight is because then we
relinquish control of this g3 square i'm
going to highlight it in orange the king
goes up to h4 and then it escapes via g3
so we need this knight to go back
and now we need this knight to go out to
g6 this is simply checkmate
now
what is the lesson we learned here well
first of all when you have these
confusing positions
a good way to get your bearings is just
to consider an obvious move see if you
can identify what the what the problem
is
and then once you do that that often
leads you to the next logical step like
oh we understand why we can't promote to
a queen so
we've kind of determined that we have to
play with checks
and my original goal was to find a way
to get black's king onto a square where
we could promote with check
and the solution wasn't actually that it
was actually just checkmate but that's
how chess thinking works
you start with one goal and then that
leads you to the solution even if the
solution
uh has a different logical aim in mind
okay so
next position
well this one also seems pretty easy
currently black is up a piece the first
thing i notice is i always start by
looking at pins
so there's a lot of pins here and the
more pins are the more tactical
potential there is
and when you have two pins combining
like this that leads to the possibility
of rook takes e6 check
all right so rook takes e6 check
black can't take back black has to move
the king away
and actually that situation is not so
simple but
i'm not saying you can kind of cheat
but here we can use process of
elimination my intuition is kind of
saying that rook takes e6 is the correct
first move just because taking a piece
like this with check well that's got to
be correct so i'm gonna i'm gonna risk
it
now this position is a little bit more
confusing because if we simply take
black's bishop
then black can now take the rook and
this is one thing i want to point out
pins are very impermanent so if you
identify a couple of pins in a position
you always have to update your board
state and you always have to make sure
that your opponent
opponents move didn't unpin
one of the pins that you had this is a
very very common way of blundering so
now black is attacking the rook
what can we do about that well
i see a couple of possibilities we can
take on c6 we can basically say if we're
losing the rook anyway we can take the
knight
black takes back
and then we take on c3
well then we've got two pieces for a
rook but that's not particularly
convincing the queen could move out to
f6
our king is also really weak there i'm
not convinced by that what else do we
have well the other thing that we can do
is we can create an est equal or
stronger threat
and using this other pin
i'm thinking about the simple rook takes
d5
that hits black's queen it gets the rook
into the game
and without doing any further
calculation it just looks devastating
look at how many pieces we're going to
have in the attack
our bishop is also going to be aiming at
f7 together with the queen but that's a
potential mating idea i think we can
just go for it rook takes d5 okay f
takes c6 is easy so we take the queen
and then we take the bishop
and we have a big material advantage
pretty easy but uh this is all about
just
brute forcing your way into it
don't get overwhelmed by the number of
hanging pieces just treat this like any
other position and remember the concept
of est like
you when you have a lot of attacking
potential oftentimes you don't have to
respond to threats directly you can just
pose stronger threats
okay 94. so
this is interesting
i don't see anything straight off the
bat
now what i do see we have a pin here
which prevents the f-pawn from moving
why is that important the other the
immediate logical step that i make is
that if we can manage
to build a battery on the long diagonal
with the queen in front
then
let's say we managed to get our queen to
c3 then we threatened checkmate on g7
and because of this other pin black will
be unable to go f6
so a situation might arise where black
is simply unable to prevent checkmate
without material losses
is there a way of getting the queen of
c3 well the move f3 comes to mind
but
when you make i mean as ben feingold
would tell us when you play f3 in any
position you have to consider the
way that you weaken your king side and
the move f3 weakens this diagonal right
it exposes it and if you look hard
enough you'll see that queen c5 check in
response to f3 basically forces the
queen trade
and then after queen takes c5 knight
takes e5
black seems to be all right they're
probably worse but all right now are
there any other ways of getting the
knight off the board well we can
literally take it let's consider the
sacrifice rook take c4
black will probably take back with a
rook and then we go queen c3
okay so we already know that black can't
play f6 does black have any other ways
of defending
g7 well black could put a piece on e5
but we have two attackers and black has
only one defender so we'll be a piece up
but wait a second after rook takes c4
rook takes c4 queen c3 black can swing
this rook to g4
and defend that square
and this is where i think a lot of
players would reject or take c4 except
you have to do one very important thing
when you calculate a line like this you
cannot fixate only on one aspect of the
position you have to take the bigger
picture view and see if there's any
other because what can happen is you
might have a sequence of moves as i said
previously that you play for one reason
right why did we take on e4 we took on
e4
in order to threaten checkmate on g7 but
in the course of making these moves it
might turn out that there's all of a
sudden some new x-ray or new pin that
maybe you didn't notice but that you
have to notice now in order to find the
correct the correct approach and that's
what happens here so rook takes c4 rook
takes c4 queen c3 rook g4 and if i look
at the whole board i will see that the
queens are facing each other
now what can we do about that well
black's queen is unprotected which means
there might be a discovery with the
bishop there is a discovery with the
bishop it is to take on f7 and expose
black's queen so we actually don't give
checkmate we win black's queen
now one of the small flaws of puzzle
rush is that they don't always have the
best continuations or the most
instructive continuations but
uh hopefully you guys were able to
follow that line
the way that they do it it's just pretty
simple we win a piece
but again if rook takes e4 had happened
then after queen c3 or q4 we would have
had to see that the queens are facing
each other the lesson here is to always
look at the whole board especially at
the end of a variation
try to see if there are any new x-rays
any new pins that you can use to do
something other than what you set out to
do initially
okay next position
well this one is a is a pretty
elementary made in two moves
um first thing i see other than the fact
that we're down a queen is this
uh x-ray against the king so that's a
potential discovery
and we have the move knight g5 check
which wins back black's queen
but you have to see the bigger picture
here which is that let's let's say we
play knight g5 check is white winning
there well not really because what
happens black's king moves away
we take black's queen
and black recaptures our knight and if
you look carefully you'll see that in
fact white is simply down upon at the
end of that line
okay so
that's why you always have to count
material and i even tell this to my high
rate of tuna to have to count the
material at the start of the exercise
because otherwise you're going to find a
way to win material and you're just
going to go for it because you think oh
we win black's queen but you're down a
queen to begin with so it's not actually
that impressive let's look for something
more ambitious where else could the
knight move to
well when you've got an x-ray you should
look for double checks because double
checks essentially force the opponent's
king to move aside
that's that's the rule because the check
is coming from two different places
there's two double checks there's knight
d6 and there's knight f6 let's compare
and contrast
well knight d6 allows the king to move
to d7 and that seems to be a dead end
what about knight f6 jack well then king
d7 is impossible the king has to move
aside to d8 and then the short could
swoop in with checkmate so this is a
pretty simple exercise but i just wanted
to deconstruct it for you remember this
mating pattern that knight i think it's
called an arabian mate the knight
supporting the rook and of course the
king unable to move to c7 because
there's a pawn there
this is all about not limiting yourself
to attempting move but instead looking
for a better one especially when it
comes to your opponent's king
okay
let's go on
and maybe after this exercise
um i can i can up the the problem range
just a little bit um and solve a couple
of of puzzles in the 2200 range before
uh before finishing the video okay so
this is another one of those where
there's a lot going on
okay so looking at this position
material okay black is up upon that's
not that important
the queen is hanging in several
different ways
so again
as i've advised one way to get your
bearings is just to consider a move like
what's the simplest move for black in
this position well it's probably to take
white's queen right what happens if we
take white's queen
well if we take white's queen probably
white is going to take back with the
rook right
and what else do i notice in that
position well i notice the black stroke
is hanging
and if we move the rook back
white can take on f7 with either piece
and
it's just a mess there right we're not
even up anything and
it appears to me that black's king is a
lot less safe than white's king even in
even in the end game so that tells me
that there's something better than just
moving the queen what could it be
well let's focus instead on some of the
assets we have we have a bishop that's
on the long diagonal always a good thing
and the h file is also open and whenever
there's an open file near your
opponent's king
that should always be considered i mean
that can be a gateway to some sort of a
tactic and
maybe many of you are seeing this on the
spot because you know this pattern but
uh the idea here is to get this king
onto the the h1 square onto this
diagonal
and um i don't have a name for this type
of tactic it's almost like replacing one
piece with another what we want to do
here is go rook h1 check
we get the king onto that square the
pawn is now pinned so in effect
the h3 square is no longer defended and
i literally like to think of it that way
if a pawn is pinned then the squares
that it would otherwise be defending are
undefended imagine that there was a
zebra on g2
and
why do i say there was a zebra rather
than nothing if there was nothing on g2
it would be hard to visualize the
position because the king would
literally be in check so let's say
there's a giraffe or a zebra andre too
what do you do well obviously you play
queen h3 and queen takes queen and the
giraffe doesn't move diagonally and it
cannot move through a pin
but because there's a pawn there i think
a lot of people have this natural
resistance to putting the queen on a
square where it can be captured even
though of course in this case it cannot
be remember that pins are
they are omnipotent you can't violate
the rules of chess so whenever there is
any kind of fin
look at the squares that would otherwise
be defended by the pinned piece you can
often put one of your pieces there to
create effect
that is exactly what happens here when
h3 and queen takes you to is checkmate
okay
actually i've changed my mind i think
i'm going i'm going to make a second
video that's going to come out
after this one where i'm going to sort
of up the rating and do some puzzles in
the 22 2500 range i think this is a
pretty good difficulty for now
but if you're if you're higher rated and
you're getting bored i will definitely
make videos uh the next video actually
will be
significantly tougher in terms of
difficulty
all right i'm thinking we can do
probably three more
and then round it off so this one i
actually recognize i've given it to some
students
this is a great
exercise and sort of understanding the
way that chest geometry works
clearly we have a situation where
black's king is really weak
counting up the material we see the
black is a piece out black is up on
knight here black has two knights
and white only has one
and so the very first thing that i see
when i look at this position is a fork
we see that the knight on e4 is
undefended maybe you also see this and
you see queen g4check or queen f5 check
and that picks off the knight
but
you know and this is maybe a little bit
of cheating but if you're actually
solving exercises and if you've solved
exercises regularly you know that
the bounds of success are greater than
just being a pawn up
and what i want you to understand here
is that even if you win this knight back
white is the material is going to be
essentially equal white is going to be
only a pawn up
for example let's say we play queen g4
check
the king drops back to e8 which is not
the best move but whatever
then we take the knight
what does black do their black probably
blocks that check with a queen and
forces an end game and in that end game
white is only a pawn up which is not the
worst case but it's also not the best
case we have to look for more
now
we have to look for more might mean
forget the concept of winning the night
but it could also mean that one of the
moves you originally made in order to
win the night might turn out to be good
for a different reason this is what i
mentioned earlier i think a lot of
people get tempted by the move queen f7
check that move just looks good
but delve into it for a second and
you'll see that after queen blocks on e7
white has absolutely no follow-up you
can give a fancy check on e6 with the
bishop because the queen can't take
but um one other
quick little detour remember that when a
piece blocks a check
the square formerly occupied by that
piece is now accessible to the king i
see this mistake all the time
in students of different ranges what
will happen is when there is a longer
line that they're visualizing they will
forget that a certain piece left a
square and now the king can move there
so after queen f7 queen e7 bishop e6
they will think that king c6 is the only
move it's not such a bad move
but king d8 is possible and white is at
a dead end
so it appears that we have to re and
checks like bishop e5 don't do anything
they're easily blocked by the pawn
so maybe we can revisit the two initial
moves we started with and see if any of
them actually produce a better result
than we thought it would
let's start with queen f5 check
now if the king moves back to e8 or e7
then wait a second i i think we can just
check mate on f7 that's a kind of a
scholars made pattern
what about queen f5 king c6
now if you forget that you can take the
knight just look at the king position
white has check made in one this bishop
on c4 guards the b5 square after queen
f5 king c6 we go queen b5
and that's simply checkmate
by the way we wouldn't have the same
thing after queen g4 because there the
king could go back to e8 or even up to
c6 and we would have no
no checkmate i spent a while on this
problem because
i think it it teaches you two things the
first is not to get fixated when you
just see a way to win a piece
but to get into the habit of looking
more ambitiously and then spending some
time and if you don't find anything then
you can always come back and
and with the piece the second is to just
appreciate the fact that you know two
pieces can can combine
uh with tremendous power in chess you
you often only need two pieces to form a
wide variety of mating patterns and
there's nothing you need to do about
that but just appreciate some of these
mating patterns and try to commit them
to memory you know the scholars mate
pattern the pattern where there's a king
on the sixth rank and then there's a
bishop and a queen creating a battery
like this just something to just
something to notice
okay
so this is an end game it appears that
we are playing black and we are moving
this way
okay so
to me it's quite clear that we need to
try to make a draw we are not going to
promote the spawn the rook can always
stop the pawn and give itself away for
it
the question is why not push the pawn up
to g2 up to b2
well probably white's going to stop it
right with rook b6
and the only thing we have there is to
move the king up to
c3
now what's going on in that position
well in that position we want to move
the king further up to c2 in order to
help the pawn promote right
is does white is white capable of doing
anything to stop that well the only
thing that i see
is white could try to give us a check
and somehow move the king to an
undesirable position
the white gives the check
the king moves the side to b3 and
something i said in the last exercise
applies here
don't forget that when a piece moves
from a square it's no longer doing the
things that it was doing there so after
the rook gives a check on c6
white has taken his eyes off of that
past pawn which can now potentially
promote
so after b2 rook b6 king c3 rook c6
check king b3
white has to stop the pawn again and so
white doesn't have anything that he can
do other than
going back to b6 and that's a repetition
of moves we are totally fine with that
because we're trying to make a draw here
so i think the move is just b2
king c3 okay king e2 doesn't accomplish
anything it just helps us accomplish our
goal
up to c2 now we don't want to go to b1
and block our own pawn
go back to b3 and we have succeeded in
holding a draw
okay let's solve one final position
now this is one on just
recognizing mating patterns
um i've advised this in a previous
puzzle solving video you should always
identify situations where your
opponent's king has no squares anytime
your opponent's king has no squares what
do i mean by that i mean
if it was a check it would be made like
there are physically no squares it can
move to
that is a very powerful precursor to a
lot of different types of combinations
because even though you might not see
immediately a way to expose the king and
give checkmate something might come up a
little bit down the line now in this
case it's just such a situation
white's king by the way is not in that
same boat it's got
d2 now if you could magically transport
this knight to g6 it would be checkmate
because the pawn is pinned
we also have a couple of heavy pieces we
have the queen of the rook if there was
no pawn on h7 it would also be checkmate
so that's another type of observation
that you could make if a certain file
was open we would be able to give
checkmate on that file that's the case
here and as it stands we have two heavy
pieces what we could do the idea that
stems from that is we could sacrifice
the queen on h7 with only one purpose
the purpose of that move is not to get
the king somewhere it's to remove that
pawn from the board and after king takes
h7 we go rook h1 and that's mate after
bishop h4 rook takes h4
notice the role of the f5 pawn that's
very important without that pawn this
would not work because the king would be
able to escape to g6 right so we have to
appreciate the role of every pawn here
this bishop is unnecessary even this
knight is unnecessary they don't play a
role in the combination boom
boom boom checkmate one other thing i'd
like to point out when you're
calculating such a line make sure
that you account for any pieces that
could block the check i often feel
that when there is a lateral that when
there's a vertical check rather that's
delivered by rook people tend to forget
that vertical checks can be blocked so
for instance let's imagine that black's
queen had been on d4 here well what
would happen then then the move bishop
h4
would actually be super effective it
would win the game for black because
uh the queen would be guarding the
bishop so remember to check for that
here bishop h4 doesn't help because that
square is undefended we just take an h4
that was a pretty simple problem kind of
an anastasia's mate but
nonetheless i think that was a helpful
helpful takeaway
okay well that was 10 problems i think
um
that's perfect for
this video um in the subsequent video i
will solve problems in i would say the
rating range 2200 to 2700 and i'm gonna
make a couple of these videos i might
also go lower and do some problems for
uh folks who just started playing um i
think problem solving is
is universally helpful at all levels and
hopefully i can cover a lot of rating
ranges well i hope you enjoyed the video
and um hopefully i wasn't didn't ramble
too much and i will see you again in the
next puzzle solving video thanks again
for watching
and uh goodbye
until the next video